>> Sean: WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU BRAND NEW SORT OF
FAR LEFT SOCIALISM HAS TAKEN
OVER THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, A
NEW RADICAL SCHISM.
THE -- RADICALISM.
THEY PUT OUT THE SOCIALIST
STAR, CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ ON THE FINANCIAL
HOUSING SERVICE COMMITTEE
WHERE MAXINE WATERS IS THE NEW
CHAIRMAN.
DON'T FORGET ABOUT BILL
DE BLASIO, COMPLAINING THERE
IS WEALTH IN NEW YORK BUT IT'S
IN THE WRONG HANDS.
WHOSE HANDS IS IT IN?
PEOPLE WHO WORK 19 HOURS A DAY
TO PAY TAXES?
ANYWAY, HE WANTS TO CONFISCATE
PRIVATE PROPERTY FROM THE LAND
LORDS IF HE DEEMS THEM
UNLIVABLE.
IN THE LEFT WING, CALIFORNIA
YOU HAVE GAVIN NEWSOM, THE NEW
GOVERNOR OF THE LAWMAKERS IN
SPITE OF A 13.5% STATE INCOME
TAX ON TOP OF THE FEDERAL
INCOME TAX, THEY NOW WANT YOU
TO PAY FOR YOUR DRINKING
WATER.
BY THE WAY, THEY ARE NOW
BANNING PAPER RECEIPTS BECAUSE
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
JOINING US IS AMERICAN FIRST
ACTION SENIOR ADVISER, SEAN
SPICER, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
TAMMY BRUCE.
YOU WERE ONCE A LIBERAL.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE THAT.
I REMEMBER IN THE DAY.
>> WELL, LIBERALISM IS NOT
THIS.
EVERYTHING YOU ARE DESCRIBING,
THIS -- REMEMBER, JOHN F.
KENNEDY DID WELL BECAUSE HE
CAMPAIGNED ON TAX CUTS.
LIBERALISM IS ALLOWING PEOPLE
TO LIVE THE LIFE THAT BEST
SUIT THEM BUT YOU CAN'T DO
THAT IF THE GOVERNMENT
CONTROLS EVERY BREATH YOU
TAKE.
THIS IS SOMETHING VERY
DIFFERENT.
GENUINE CLASSICAL LIBERALISM
IS GETTING THE PEOPLE AND THE
GOVERNMENT OFF YOUR BACK,
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY AND
BEING LEFT ALONE BUT BEING
RESPONSIBLE CITIZEN.
THAT IS WHAT LIBERALISM IS.
BUT IT'S NOT GOING ON HERE.
NOT COINCIDENCE THAT BILL
DE BLASIO AND GAVIN NEWSOM IN
THE SAME WEEK ANNOUNCED
EXPANSION OF HEALTHCARE FOR
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
KEEP IN MIND WHAT IT MEANS.
>> Sean: WHAT PAYS FOR THAT?
>> NOT ONLY WHO PAYS FOR IT
BUT THE BILL DE BLASIO PLAN
WON'T TAKE EFFECT OR WORK
UNTIL AFTER 2021.
I CONTEND ALL OF THIS AND
SEAN, YOU MIGHT ASQUARE.
BOTH -- YOU MIGHT AGREE.
SEAN SQUARED.
>> SEAN STEREO.
>> THIS IS ABOUT ORGANIZING
AND GETTING OUT THE VOTE AND
REGISTERING YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
NEVER HAVE BEEN REGISTERED
BEFORE.
SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO DELIVER.
THEY ARE TALKING UP ALL OF
THIS STUFF.
THE SAME THING WITH THE NEW
GREEN DEAL.
IT'S ABOUT HUBS OF REGISTERING
YOUNG PEOPLE, ORGANIZING THEM
AND GETTING THEM TO VOTE.
THE REPUBLICANS DON'T HAVE
SOMETHING COMPARABLE.
DONALD TRUMP IS ONE TO MAKE
SOMETHING HAPPEN.
THAT IS WHAT THIS IS.
I THINK THAT WE AS THE
REPUBLICANS THAT WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED WITH THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY OR THE
CONSERVATIVES.
I'M STILL A DEMOCRAT IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE DISAPPOINTED WHEN YOU
ARE TOLD ONE THING AND IT DOES
NOT HAPPEN.
LIKE REPEALING AND REPLACEING
OBAMACARE.
A LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE WILL BE
DISAPPOINTED WHEN THEY FIND
OUT THEY ARE USED FOR VOTES
FOR 2020 FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT
TO STAY IN POWER.
>> LOOK, TAMMY IS RIGHT WE ARE
SELLING SOCIALISM AS A GOOD
THING FOR PEOPLE IN AMERICA.
WE DON'T REMIND THEM PEOPLE
FLEE VENEZUELA BECAUSE
SOCIALISM IS A BAD THING.
THEY FREE TO COME TO AMERICA
WHERE THE AMERICAN DREAM IS
WHAT PEOPLE WANT TOES A SPARE
TO.
CAPITALISM IS AT THE ROOT OF
THIS.
WE MADE IT A NEGATIVE WORD
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS
DEMONIZED HARD WORK AND THE
CAPITALISM.
WE HAVE TO REMIND PEOPLE, WE
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT WHAT IS AT
STAKE.
TRUMP LED FIGHT FOR TAX REFORM
TO ALLOW PEOPLE KEEP MORE OF
WHAT THEY EARN AND PUT THEIR
FAMILIES IN A BETTER POSITION
AND SAVE MORE FOR THE COLLEGE
EDUCATION OR ALLOW THEM TO
PREPARE THE HOUSE OR TAKE
VACATION IN A WAY THEY HADN'T
FOR YEARS UNDER OBAMA.
THE IDEA THAT SOCIALISM IS
COOL IS IGNORING WHAT HAPPENED
IN HISTORY.
PEOPLE FLED SOCIALISTS
COUNTRIES FOR A REASON.
WE HAVE FORGOTTEN TO TELL THAT
STORY.
>> Sean: WHAT ARE THE
REASONS THAT NANCY PELOSI, YOU
KNOW, DOLLAR FOR THE WALL
PELOSI.
SHE CAN'T MAKE A DEAL WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
BECAUSE THAT BASE, THAT NOW
RUNS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN
CONGRESS, HER BASE WILL TURN
ON HER IN A LICKETY SPLIT
SECOND.
>> NOT ONLY THAT.
BUT TAMMY, THE POINT SHE MADE
WHEN SHE WAS SAYING IS EQUALLY
IMPORTANT.
EVERY ONE OF THE FOLKS IS
RUNNING OR THINKING OF RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS TRYING
TO STAKE OUT THE FURTHEST
POSITION LEFT SO THAT THEY CAN
GET THE GROUP OF THE KEY
VOTERS.
>> LET ME JUST SAY, THOUGH, IT
IS GOING TO BE UP TO THE
REPUBLICANS, TO THE PRESIDENT.
TO EVERYONE WHO CARES ABOUT
THE COUNTRY TO IN FACT SPEAK
UP ABOUT THIS.
>> YES.
>> AND AGAINST IT.
THEY ARE RELYING ON THE
REPUBLICANS BEING DEFENSIVE.
NOT EDUCATING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND THEY ARE THE ONLY ONES WHO
WILL HAVE TO DO IT.
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW THIS IS A
FAILED DYNAMIC.
THEY DON'T EVEN REALLY EXPECT
TO IMPLEMENT IT.
THEY ARE LAYING TO THE
CONSTITUENCY -- LYING TO THE
CONSTITUENCY.
THIS NATION IS AT STAKE.
WHAT THE REPUBLICANS AND WHAT
THE PRESIDENT IN PARTICULAR
CHOOSES TO DO IN EDUCATING,
ESPECIALLY YOUNG PEOPLE WILL
BE KEY.
>> Sean: VERY APPEALING.
WHAT THEY WILL DO, THIS IS A
POWER PLAY, TOO.
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING WE'LL
TAKE THEIR MONEY, CONFISCATE
IT AND GIVE IT TO YOU.
VOTE FOR ME.
>> MOST AMERICANS WON'T AGREE
WITH THAT.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER AMERICAN
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE THAT.
THEY WANT FAIRNESS.
THAT IS NOT FAIRNESS.
>> Sean: BOTTOM 50% OF THE
WAGE EARNERS PAY 2% OF THE
INCOME TAX BILL.
2%.
>> BUT EVERYONE IS DOING
BETTER AND THEY WILL CONTINUE
TO DO BETTER UNDER PRESIDENT